[Music]
do you use a service mesh and worry
about compliance learn how to use a
private certificate authority to improve
security strengthen compliance and
reduce headaches today we'll learn about
certificate authority service its
integration with antho service mesh and
how they work together to achieve your
goals
antho service mesh or asm security helps
you mitigate insider threats and reduce
the risk of a data breach by ensuring
that all communications between
workloads are encrypted mutually
authenticated and authorized leveraging
industry standards like mutual tls or
mtls for short
asm offers a slew of security benefits
it mitigates risk of replay or
impersonation attacks that use stolen
credentials ensures encryption in
transit mitigates the risk of user data
breach within your production network by
ensuring that only authorized clients
can access a service and identifies
which clients accessed a service with
sensitive data
antho service mesh includes a google
managed multi-regional private
certificate authority mesh ca for
issuing certificates for mtls but what
do you do if you need to back your ca
signing keys in a google managed hsn or
in a highly regulated industry and are
subject to compliance or need
flexibility with your on-prem route to
move between clouds without being tied
to a specific provider
q certificate authority service which
can replace mesh ca
cas is a highly available scalable
service that enables you to simplify
automate and customize the deployment
management and security of private
certificate authorities or cas
it allows you to converge all of your
certifications ncas into a single
management pane to reduce your risk and
increase the control and visibility over
the operations in your org
do you have a situation where one team
handles all the certifications or where
certifications can be made without
appropriate visibility for security and
compliance teams
cas removes the bottlenecks and
increases visibility and therefore
security by providing guard rails cis
does this by defining granular access
controls and virtual security parameters
defining per user group insurance policy
and baseline certificate extensions
storing ca keys in cloud hsm which is
fips 140-2 level 3 validated and can
help achieve various compliance
certifications like fedramp and soc
and by obtaining logs and gaining
visibility into who did what
when and where with cloud audit logs
additionally it's configured by you
giving you control over your
infrastructure
to recap cas allows you to converge all
of your certifications and cas into a
single management pane it reduces your
risk by providing guardrails for usage
and increases the control and visibility
over operations in your org while
simultaneously removing bottlenecks
allowing for increased efficiency
and you can easily install it right in
the command line to install certificate
authority service with antho service
mesh and if you want to learn how to
create a certificate authority check out
the links in the description for a
helpful video and documentation
[Music]